so within that six-month time frame was
your plan to maybe get some head shots
enroll in a screenwriting course may be
acting and look for a general manager no
no I I was skeptical of the whole thing
I didn't want to be a guy waiting in
line with a headshot begging for an
opportunity and I'm going to
stubbornness a pride it's just not my
style I I really had no desire to be an
actor I you know I have my moments world
funny but as far as actually wanting to
be quote unquote talent it's never been
my thing so i really wasn't motivated by
that I hated writing absolutely hit I
like to talk don't ask you to write I
can't write a conversation but I can
talk for hours just give me some food
and water and a toilet I can go I shall
I could've been a fantastic senator
because there's no limits of how long
you can talk but no I mean I start here
with the expansion then you start
hearing all these different views on
head shot as well they're going to this
agent will tell you to use their guy
because they're getting a kickback and I
heard these stories about people that
would get head shots and then they bring
into an able those no-good you got to
use these go to another agent those
no-good gotta use these and before you
know it you've got 15 sets of headshots
and no job it just didn't make sense to
me as far as far as writing goes you
know trying to organize for people to
finish a script for different
personalities all have their different
visions on top of the fact somebody used
to get a frickin job it just it was a
bad plan so my focus was first and
foremost get money coming in somehow
someway get a job pay your bills once
you've got a roof over your head you've
got food you know you make your car
payment yeah gasps the vehicle then you
can worry about all that so the
practicality of the situation came into
play real soon for me that's my
personality what do you think of the
percent or so in LA who go that waiting
in line route maybe they don't see it
that way what that's what they don't
mean I think they don't I think they
think that they're going to be the one
and maybe they will be but I've never
done statistical analysis on what
percentage of people who do that
actually succeed as I've gotten older
one of the things i find fascinating is
you'll see someone come up and their
name is completely different than an
older celebrity and then you'll find out
oh that's their nephew or you know
that's that was their step parent or
that was the illegitimate kid of so and
so you know then you find out that there
are certain it's actually a very small
community of the real successful actors
it get your shot but i think in
hollywood I don't know if this applies
to the radio business but connections
are very important and getting
discovered and you know getting someone
like a camera is she got discovered at a
party no she was a hot blonde chick
she's a mom yeah but she didn't get
discovered for remodeling she was at an
event in someone discovered her so you
know to me it's just not it's from a
practicality standpoint it's not the
best plan it's not to say that it's a
bad plan it just wasn't the right one
for me I think that you're probably
better off getting close to the target
in another way and what I mean by that
is what I did radio instead of sending
out 5,000 demo tapes and hoping somebody
would actually listen to most end up in
the trash actually working in the
business behind the scenes
learn about learn how it works learn how
these different hosts got to be hosts
talk to them you know you can't expect
the hit a target if you can get close to
it and if all you're doing is you know
on the other side of the hills lobbing
shells hoping you're going to get wood
should be better off charging the hill
and getting close and see what's on the
other side you might not hit the target
but you have a better shot up close and
so that's all I try to do is I try to
close the gap between where I wanted to
be and where I was at that's it
you